[Musik]
auch tage später fällt noch schwer es zu
begreifen
das geschieht nicht irgendwo auf fernen
kontinenten das ist bei uns unsere
nachbarn hilflos in der brütenden natur
hier unten die leute eine mörderische
wetter laune oder doch ein einschnitt
vielleicht ein weckruf
deutschland in schock und trauer muss
aufräumen und die lage wirklich relativ
dramatisch aber was soll wir machen
außer anpacken
am anfang ist es einfach nur schlechtes
wetter der sommer scheint endgültig ins
wasser gefallen zu sein zumindest den
westen und im süden da gehst es wie aus
kannen die meteorologen sprechen von
einer luftmassengrenze und sie sprechen
sehr oft vom regen tief bernd und wir
fragen uns ja woher hat bernd dieses
ganze wasser dass die verträge der irrt
sich immer wieder
es schlaucht die warme und feuchte luft
aus richtung mittelmeer ein gleichzeitig
vermixt ist das dann mit der kühleren
und trockenen luft vom atlantik und
deswegen gibt es so enorme regenmengen
es ist einfach ausgedrückt der perfekte
sturm
im erzgebirge merken sie es zuerst das
ist nicht nur regen
es ist flut schon am dienstagabend
kämpfen die sachsen mit dem braunen
sturzbächen die sich in minutenschnelle
ihrer siedlung in ihrer häuser und ihrer
keller bemächtigen ingolstadt wird ein
nachbar vom wasser mitgerissen als er
sein grundstück sichern will
seit dem verheerenden hochwasser von
haben sie so was hier nicht mehr erlebt
mannheim stimmt es ist gesamte
explodiert muss man doch da ist dabei
sind schnell übergesprungen
so schnell kommt noch reagieren für
irgendwelche hilfen verzichten straßen
unpassierbar ortschaften abgeschnitten
die feuerwehren im dauereinsatz hier
zeichnet sich dramatisch ab was unser
land in den nächsten tagen bestimmen
wird
weiter westlich ruft nach wolkenbruch
und hagelschlag der landkreis hof den
katastrophenfall aus nach dem vielerorts
der straßenverkehr in einer wasser wüste
endet der fahrbahnverlauf lässt sich nur
erahnen und mit mulmigen gefühl tasten
sich die fahrer heimwärts hoffentlich
sind die fenster zu ich habe oben die
fenstern immer schnell geschlossen nicht
einmal der dieser tage wieder zu hause
und damit dann bin ich traurig bin ich
raus habe ich gebe wo kommt das wasser
jetzt auch mal mehr und habe gesehen wie
der august durch einfach durch diese war
so machen einfach durchlaufen deshalb
über hab ich selber noch nie erlebt kann
das abwasser aus den toiletten
geschossen und das war besonders
interessant und lecker also das war
unglaublich wir wissen ja dass vor allem
hier im viertel sehr viele probleme im
keller gibt dass die immer unter wasser
stehen und aber das ist jetzt so weit
bis an die tür kommt oder überhaupt dass
wir uns noch so stehen hätten wir
natürlich niemals gedacht wir erwarten
vor allem auf die feuerwehr das sieht
natürlich so schnell wie möglich etwas
machen
jeder wartet auf die feuerwehr 200 mal
müssen die helfer in dieser nacht
ausrücken
die notfallnummern sind hoffnungslos
überlastet mit fast 1000 leuten sind die
wehren unterwegs um abzupumpen
umzuleiten frei zu räumen und an
strategischen stellen sandsack
barrikaden zu errichten
hinter jeder ecke wartet der nächste
tosende bach der nächste geflutete
keller der nächste von einer heftigen
sturmböe umgestürzte baum
das wird mir jetzt einfach nach und nach
abgearbeitet und die auch durch
priorisiert also leute partien scott
dringender ist die kommerziellen und ja
dann müssen heute manche auch mehr
warten wir haben wir einfach nicht mehr
leute gott und noch bevor die helfer in
hof allen wasser geschädigten zur seite
stehen können öffnen sich die schleusen
der regen walze namens bernd 330
kilometer westlich über dem ruhrgebiet
dem sauerland und der eisen
während ganze landstriche dazwischen und
dann eben zwar einigen regen aber keine
sintflut abbekommen meldet hagen die
schwersten regengüsse seit
menschengedenken
diese dunklen stunden werden die
menschen hier noch lange verfolgen die
nacht der gefluteten keller
unterführungen und tiefgaragen der
deutsche wetterdienst warnt die
bevölkerung mit einer schier
unglaublichen zahl 200 liter pro
quadratmeter werden an manchen orten
erwartet das doppelte des
durchschnittlichen monats regens aber
innerhalb von wenigen stunden die
begradigten und einbetonierten
flussläufe kommen da nicht mit die
kanäle laufen über wo das wasser nicht
abfließen kann wird es zur gefahr
überall strom aus filme jetzt werden
straßen gesperrt und der bahnverkehr
kommt zum erliegen
[Musik]
ich muss ja zur arbeit aber leider komme
ich hier nicht weg ich muss ein bisschen
arbeiten zur arbeit
und wie man sieht ist ja alles so daher
keine ahnung ist gehen soll
und so wie es aussieht war nie wo sie
aber auch nicht nein die größe bleiben
in den betroffenen gemeinden tatsächlich
liebe depots und die behörden empfehlen
den bürgern ohnehin wenn möglich das
haus nicht zu verlassen
nichts geht mehr
wie zdf reporterin ariane güdel im
niederbergischen land feststellen muss
ja wir stehen hier in erkrath und es
regnet und regnet wird eigentlich immer
schlimmer in erkrath ist heute die
düssel über die ufer getreten und das
thw hat viele menschen aus ihrem zuhause
gerettet und in sicherheit gebracht
es kommt immer mehr wassermenge unter
teilweise 200 liter auf den quadratmeter
und man sieht hier hinter mir die straße
verwandelt sich ja das geht minütlich
wird es schlimmer in einen reissenden
bach und die goalies können einfach
diese wassermassen gar nicht mehr
auffangen und das nicht nur hier sondern
eigentlich im ganzen land in düsseldorf
sind gab es evakuierungen in bonn den
unterführungen gesperrt wenn man die
straßen benutzen könnte treffe man nach
30 autominuten richtung osten den
kollegen thomas münten auf der brücke
über der wupper gestern abend war sehr
sehr kritisch geworden weil die
wuppertalsperre in radevormwald die ganz
am ende dieses kleinen flusses liegt
drohte überzulaufen dann hat man sie ein
wenig geöffnet übergelaufen ist sie dann
aber trotzdem genauso wie die
bevertalsperre direkt daneben und das
ergebnis dieses überlaufe sieht man hier
wenn man mal in den jetzt reißenden
fluss schaut hier an der alexander
brücke das gebäude hier ist sozusagen
eine schwebebahn haltestelle die
schwebebahn fährt aber nicht und dieser
fluss hier ist normalerweise ja sagen
wir mal zweieinhalb drei meter breit und
vielleicht 70 cm bis einen meter tief im
moment haben wir hier zwölf bis 15 meter
breite bei drei meter vierzig wasserhöhe
und genau das ist das problem denn die
stadt wuppertal liegt
rund um diesen fluss herum und zwar
tiefer als der fluss einen apotheken-
und arzt gebäude das direkt an der
wupper gebaut war
da ist durch die belüftungsanlage wasser
eingedrungen und hat die apotheke die im
erdgeschoss hat den keller und die
apotheke ungefähr 50 cm hoch geflutet
soll heißen wasserhöhe im gebäude
ungefähr drei meter nicht nur die
berühmte schwebebahn steht still
inzwischen sind viele haushalte ohne
strom telefon und internet das handynetz
ist längst nicht mehr erreichbar die
feuerwehr bekommt es auch hier mit einer
der unsichtbaren gefahren zu tun mit
gekappten stromleitungen
hier ist zum einen der gefahr des stroms
weil er die leitung strom führend sind
um hier den stadtteil mit strom zu
versorgen sondern lässt sich hier um
eine mittelspannungsleitung mit 10.000
volt weitergehend ist natürlich die
gefahr des wassers weitergegeben die
pegel steigen da ist nicht mehr viel
platz zu den ebenen wo wir uns aufhalten
wo wir uns bewegen
aus diesem grund sind etwa 200 meter
stromabwärts strömungsretter der das
dlrg eingesetzt die im zweifel wenn ein
helfer oder ein feuerwehrangehöriger
feuerwehrangehörige mitgerissen werden
sollte dort denjenigen dann aus dem
wasser holen können und vor dem
ertrinken retten können wo keine geübten
strömungsretter warten verhindernde
herzte anwohner das schlimmste
und fischen einen retter in not aus den
fluten
wir sind in altena wo in dieser nacht
zwei feuerwehrleute nicht solches glück
hatten und im einsatz zu tode kamen
ich weiß dass ein feuer wenn man
gestorben ist janko in zwei autos haus
gezogen die sich festgefahren haben und
die werden ja ich weiß nicht ob sie
ertrunken werden aber zumindest wenn die
autos recht gewesen
man kann nur hoffen dass keiner mehr
drin sitzt
von altena an der schwelle zum sauerland
liegt zdf-reporter tadeusz parade
entlang der braunen schlamm spuren des
platz hier mit gewaltiger kraft gestern
eingegangen ist in die stadthäuser die
sich im uferbereich befinden sind
prächtig hier unter wasser die ganze
cooper promenade unter wasser
mittlerweile ist der wasserstand wieder
deutlich gesunken so an dieser auswahl
straße sieht man auch nochmal mit
welcher kraft hier das wasser an dieser
stelle zum beispiel die ganze straße
weggerissen hat diese unpassierbar
hier sieht man die a1 richtung süden
komplett gesperrt und ich brauchte
gestaut
das sind
sich kilometer
und kompletter stillstand
sieht man jetzt sehr guten grund der
vollsperrung auf der a1 thema kreuz a31
komplett unter wasser
ein lastwagen liegt nur in den fluten
kamen nicht weiter und man sieht zu
kommen sondern auch hier schon dass das
wasser deutlich höheren noch bestanden
hat heute morgen und in den nachtstunden
der frieden jetzt in richtung
steinbachtalsperre kreis euskirchen auch
eine talsperre dramatisch gefüllt ist
und verdammt brot zu brechen
man sieht von hier auch ganz deutlich
wie beschädigt schon ja dann ist und das
ist wahrscheinlich
möglicherweise wirklich nicht mehr lange
halten wird von dem beliebten
naherholungsgebiet bei euskirchen geht
plötzlich eine große gefahr aus ein
abgasrohr ist verstopft die wassermenge
kann nicht kontrolliert verringert
werden
einen dammbruch würden womöglich viele
häuser der tiefer liegenden gemeinden
nicht überstehen
feuerwehr und thw pumpen was die geräte
hergeben um den angeschwollenen stausee
zu entlasten
bis zur grenze der eigenen kräfte und
darüber hinaus die situation ist eben
wenig schlaf man muss dazu sagen dass
die einsatzkräfte sich verpflichtet
fühlen also es ist tatsächlich so dass
man weiß man braucht den schlaf und man
möchte das auch gerne machen man weiß
aber auch mal möchte kameraden vor ort
nicht im stich lassen und bewegt sich
dann in den frühen morgenstunden schon
wieder zum gerätehaus um eben auch dabei
zu sein um zu helfen weil man eben weiß
wie verzweifelt einige menschen in
gerade im stadtbereich um hilfe ringen
euskirchen ist nur einer der landkreise
die in diesen tagen in große not geraten
und so aus dem regen mehr wird als ein
unwetter es überschreitet hier und in
vielen anderen dörfern und kleinstädten
mehr und mehr die schwelle zur
katastrophe
allein in dieser gegend werden die
einsatzkräfte bis zum freitagmorgen 24
tote bergen müssen manche ertrunken in
ihren kellern von stromschlägen getötet
von den fluten fortgerissen
hier zeigt sich auch eine erschreckende
besonderheit dieses hochwassers es sind
nicht die großen flüsse die die
schlimmsten wunden ins land schlagen
sind ihre kleinen zuläufe die zu
wildwasser werden und deren namen oft
nur die anwohner kennen die erft die
düssel die grünen dienst die jagst die a
die schwellen die wupper und dies ist
mein sohn ging in den garten papa papa
komm ganz schön ist es da ich habe
gefragt willst du mich verarschen ich
bin raus gerannt und habe ich schon den
assist gestanden bin ich drauf andrea
wir müssen wir haben verloren wir müssen
gehen ist es im garten und da kam die
auch schon rein
die türen herausgerissen alles und der
katze kellers von es stinkt nach
betriebsstoffen das ganze aus stimmt
nach öl nach diesel
wer weiß was alles teilen dem wasser
drin ist
irgendwo dort unten unterspült und
versunken im schlamm verläuft nicht weit
von hier in der voreifel die grenze nach
rheinland pfalz und ins gebirge an
dessen straßen das traurige treibgut der
sturm nächte gesammelt wird von dessen
steilen hängen und berühmten weinbergen
und auch aus den hochlagen der eifel
drückten die zuläufe die tagelange regen
führt zum rhein hinunter und rissen
alles mit was sich ihnen in den weg
stellte
auch die mittelalterlichen stadtmauern
konnten nichts bewirken und er überhaupt
ein auge zugemacht hat in dieser nacht
in ahrweiler der wacht am donnerstag in
einem trümmerfeld
bei sechs metern so wird berichtet habe
der wasserstandsmeldung der irgendwann
in der nacht den dienst quittiert 19
tote hat die stadt zu betrauern im kreis
steigt die zahl bald auf 110 todesopfer
viele werden noch vermisst
sind all diese menschen opfer eines
grausamen zufalls geworden einer
einzigartigen laune das wetter so da
gibt es andere gründe
ich hab's mir damit gerechnet dass hier
wasser rein kommt aber nicht so was
wobei meine eltern mein vater und meine
großeltern hatten schon immer angst dass
irgendwann mal was dann nach ahrweiler
reinkommen weil es von jahrzehnt zu
jahrzehnt immer mehr geworden ist haben
sie gesagt irgendwann ist die stadt
zugelaufen um den verlust zu begreifen
müsste man die ursachen kennen war das
regentief bernd ein einmaliges unglück
oder doch vorbote des klimawandels auch
darüber reden sie in den verschlammten
gassen der betroffenen ortschaften und
auch in den fernsehstudios
[Musik]
was kannst du dazu sagen also dazu kann
man sagen dass die gesamte
klimaforschung sich einig ist dass im
zuge der globalen erwärmung extremwetter
wie diese die wir jetzt gerade erleben
einfach häufiger werden also wir hatten
ja in den letzten drei sommern
unheimliche hitze das war ein extrem und
dieses ist ein anderes extrem
tatsächlich ist es so dass es
tiefdruckgebiete wie das tief bernd die
sich für lange zeit über eine region
festhalten und austoben schon immer gab
dass sie häufiger werden liegt daran
dass die arktis und die luft darüber
immer wärmer werden und dem jetstream
dem antrieb des wettergeschehens die
kraft entziehen
also liegt es am klimawandel die folgen
sind spürbar nicht irgendwann irgendwo
sondern jetzt
und hier jetzt und hier
denn das ist nicht der monsun in indien
oder ein tsunami in japan
das ist das dörfchen schuld an der a
oder besser in der die den ort mit einer
flussschleife in ihrer umarmung nimmt
und in der nacht zum donnerstag beinahe
erdrückt
da ging ja so schnell mit mir konnte
nichts mehr retten darum das war's da
kam durch dann habe ich noch nicht
gesehen wir waren auf der brücke und
dann sagte sie noch eng werden
und dann war schon sein dass stich durch
permanent hoch habe ich ihr top pick im
wattenmeer walter autos nichts mehr
alles weg bahrain war alles weg
hier unten die leute oh gott oh gott
wenn wir dann gesehen hat wie die
wassermassen hier durchkommen mit
gastanks und traktoren lkws einfach nur
katastrophal ist schrecklich und wenn
man das jetzt sieht hier hinter uns
haben zwei häuser gestanden
man sieht ja wie viele häuser kaputt ist
er ist im stück sind sie wisse nicht
mehr wissen gar nicht wie es weitergeht
ist alles weg gesprochen alles kaputt
halbe mio
schaden was wir machen sollen
wie durch ein wunder können sich alle
aus dem todessturz retten keiner geht
verloren aber häuser brechen weg mauern
stürzten ein unter dem druck der wellen
und dem was sie aus haushalten scheunen
und wäldern rauben konnten verschlungen
zu unentwirrbaren material bündel zu
klumpen von baumstämmen hausrat und
baustoffen
zdf-reporter bobic irian war als einer
der ersten journalisten in dem
unbewohnbaren dorf die menschen sind
dann entweder bei familien oder freunden
untergekommen
das haben wir hier mitbekommen auch zum
teil außerhalb von rheinland pfalz
wiederum andere haben das angebot von
hoteliers hier aus der gegend angenommen
kostenfrei in hotelzimmern zu
übernachten und haben dort
dementsprechend auch verpflegung
bekommen
die einsatzkräfte werden sich jetzt
anschauen wie es hier weitergeht
bausachverständige sollen schauen welche
gebäude waren abgerissen werden müssen
die polizei hat das areal in der nacht
kontrolliert denn so hat die
einsatzleitung gesagt es ist zu
plünderungen gekommen
nur kurz dürfen die bewohner daheim nach
dem rechten sehen
ein jahr
[Musik]
warum
da hat sich ein baumstamm im wohnzimmer
breitgemacht
ich weiß noch nicht wie das alles geht
oder ob man vielleicht abreisen muss
aber dort entdeckt die 19 jährige ihren
pullover im vorgarten
ich hatte den schock gestern schon
deswegen heute kann ich schon wieder da
ich einfach nicht umsonst machen soll
außer lachen ich es tut so weh keine
ahnung weshalb irgendwie alles weg trost
ist immer der letzte akt im alten und
der erste akt im neuen leben
und während sie in schuld anpacken und
sich an die mammut aufgabe des sommers
und aufräumens machen tut sich 40
kilometer nördlich die erde auf
erftstadt in nrw stadtteil blessem
ausgewaschen vom dauerregen angenagt von
der strömung rutscht rund um eine
kiesgrube die ganze landschaft einfach
weg verwandelt sich der ortsrat in einen
krater feld reist drei wohnhäuser und
teile eines baudenkmals mit und die
weizenernte gleich dazu
auf der untergegangenen bundesstraße 265
gleich nebenan sind soldaten der
bundeswehr mit ihren radpanzern im
einsatz um gestrandete wracks zu bergen
beobachtet auch von zdf korrespondentin
dorte ferber
diese straße ist seit donnerstag
überfluten sind seit dem vormittag dem
morgen versucht man mit schwerem
räumgerät die straße wieder frei zu
bekommen
das ist keine einfache aufgabe für die
retter den sie wussten nicht ob sie dort
vielleicht auch personen in den
fahrzeugen vorfinden das war
glücklicherweise nicht der fall von
allmählich geht das wasser auch zurück
allerdings bleibt die situation brisant
denn wir sind hier ungefähr einen halben
kilometer von der kiesgrube entfernt und
dort herrscht weiter akute ab
rutschgefahr
das sind auch keine helfer im einsatz
rund 100 meter um diese kiesgrube herum
und auf der anderen seite ist die
steinbachtalsperre und dort ist auch
keine entfernung bislang die wird
abgelassen kontrolliert aber erst wenn
zwei drittel dieser talsperre dann
abgelassen sind dass es morgen
nachmittag dann kann wirklich entwarnung
gegeben werden also insoweit es bleibt
riskant hier
wohin man auch fährt wo man auch stoppt
und sich umsieht im rhein-sieg-kreis in
kleinen form als unbekannten orten wo
immer ein flüsschen vielleicht auch nur
ein bächlein floss ist nichts mehr wie
zuvor
swisttal odendorf nur ein beispiel den
orbach der hier jahrelang friedlich
durch sein betonbett plätschert hatte
nie einer als bedrohung empfunden mit
der note kommt nun die angst vergessen
worden zu sein und die ungewissheit weil
es viele gerüchte aber wenig
informationen gibt
ganzen tag am heute keinen gesehen
wieder vom thw noch von der feuerwehr
aus dem hubschrauber immer die aussage
geht immer in die verkehrte richtung
immer falschmeldungen wie ein evakuiert
bundeswehr kommt sie werden abgeholt
schnellsten frau aus der eine sagte dahm
ist gebrochen der nächste seit jahren
dem gesprengt viele deren häuser
unbewohnbar sind oder in gefahrenzonen
liegen müssen in den notunterkünften
bleiben wo sie einander ihre oft
schlimmen erlebnisse schildern und
vielleicht ein bisschen trost unter
leidensgenossen finden können
er ist der keller voll und dann auch das
haus unten
das ist mein keller gerade noch überlebt
das werk der firma im onkel nehmen um 19
alles weg keine möbel teilen
noch gebrauchen können aber niemand muss
sich allein und vergessen fühlen viele
nachbarn die verschont blieben bringen
kleidung nahrung spielsachen zb in den
kindergarten wo einige familien
untergekommen sind das für mich
schlimmste war glaube ich waren die
mütter die ihre kleinen kinder suchen
also sicher waren echt mutter die ihren
dreijährigen suchen zweijährigen die
waren bei den großeltern kein kontakt
mehr weil kein strom genau da ist also
für mich der materielle wert einfach
weniger wert als das ja das war schon
aber auch man kennt einfach so viele die
jetzt ja einfach nicht wissen wohin nun
rollt eine andere delle eine von der
guten sorte eine welle der
hilfsbereitschaft
überall im land wird gespendet und
gesammelt nur ein paar stunden nach dem
aufruf in den sozialen netzwerken kann
sich die feuerwehr in nieder-olm bei
mainz vorgaben aller art und größe kaum
noch retten
weil sie jetzt ganz schön der hof ist
voll also der ist durchgehend voll
wir haben begonnen um 8 uhr um 8 uhr 30
war hier die hütte der die ist schon aus
allen nähten geplatzt
küchenutensilien und kuscheltiere
kleidungsstücke hygieneartikel und
verpflegung bald sind die lagerhallen
voll
und statt wie geplant einer wird es nun
mehrere lkw fahrten in die eifel geben
weinend vor glück hat so viele leute
gibt die dafür spenden sagen haben so
viele sachen und uns geht's gut und
somit dass wir in ganz vielen teilen
abgeben können
ähnliche szenen von freigiebigkeit und
solidarität kommen aus trier das selbst
schwer vom hochwasser erwischt wurde und
wo 130 flut geschädigte für die erste
nacht auf feldbetten in einer schule
untergekommen sind mitnehmen konnten sie
nichts aus ihren häusern manche kamen
mit nassen kleidern jahren getroffen
hätte mich zum beispiel dass auch jemand
kommen würde und wird sagen hier hast
eine rolle klopapier ist ja ein
das klingt so lächerlich aber ist der
sohn so wichtig so eine kleine sache die
übersicht hat machbar und deshalb denke
ich mal selbstverständlich für uns als
gesellschaft als menschen dass wir alle
helfen
[Musik]
dass nun kein mensch allein sein muss in
trauer und schmerz in chaos und schmutz
und den zertrümmerten besudelten
überresten seiner habe das wünschen nun
alle und viele tun etwas
wenn ich darüber nachdenke was was hier
passiert haben neben uns zweit im auto
gesessen und erst mal geweint vor glück
weil die leute zu uns graphen ist
überzeugt er die solidarität weil wir so
viele helfen die bringt schmieren
belegte brötchen dass er weiß wo ich
wirklich gern dort bekomme nachbarn
freunde familie eilen herbei und packen
mit an
jetzt wo der regen endlich weiter
gezogen ist und die sonne wieder scheint
jetzt wo der erste schreck und die
größte angst überwunden sind jetzt muss
sich jeder seinen verlusten stellen
seinen schmerz und seine wut überwinden
und seinen mut finden wir räumen darauf
weisen nur die sachen weg weil ihr
gibt's nichts zu retten
die kühlung im saarland der keller es
voll schwimmt die wahl das ist einfach
nicht so zu kaufen
man hat so lange zeit gebraucht werden
aufzubauen und bringe jetzt ist und
jetzt nach der pandemie noch mal so eine
katastrophe
[Musik]
oft haben wir ja gestaunt wenn irgendwo
im fernen ländern die natur so grausam
hütete wie die menschen wieder
aufstanden und zupackten sich nicht
besiegen ließen
[Musik]
woher kommt diese kraft haben sich viele
gefragt genau diese kraft wird jetzt bei
uns gebraucht dramatisch aber hat sorgen
machen außer anpacken
[Musik]
vielleicht kommt die kraft das der
gemeinschaft dem mitfühlen dem mithelfen
vielleicht ist es tatsächlich so dass es
die schlimmsten momente sind die das
beste in uns zum vorschein bringen
[Musik]